investigators who
've reached out to Adult Protective
Services
HPD victim Services has reached out
we've also connected Rudy with victim
services to ensure that
he has a method to recover
now based on Rudy's interview there were
no reports of sexual abuse reported
if there is a disclosure made we will
continue to investigate currently the
investigation is active
and there are new leads coming in we'll
continue to follow those leads
we do take all allegations seriously
and any new information or facts that we
received will be investigated
thank you lieutenant one question at a
time please
is
flota
no todos neces
vehicles and investigations is
vehicles
vehicles necessaries
is that
detectives
the
esta Persona enters is
Rudy
celebrate
division is
acts and he made some shocking
allegations that he was a detective and
he
and that he was drugged by his mother
from what you just said today are you
saying that the activist was lying
basically what we're saying is all
investigation is our investigation and
we treat it the same uh we're gonna
um our investigators were in the room
and basically you know what what they
heard and what they interviewed that's
what we attest to in all offense reports
and all investigations and I'm not here
neither are they here to question
anybody's Integrity but our integrity
with the Houston Police Department
stands and and we're going to report and
put in offense reports what a victim our
potential victim tells us okay
go ahead
yeah Sergeant Stephanie's uh yes I
interviewed him and no uh there was no
you know I'm trained to to listen for
probable cause I'm trained to listen for
statements that can help me get charges
or or move for forward with the case and
no I there was no statements made during
this investigation so far no thank you
next question go ahead Mario
wait a minute go ahead okay we get it
was there any conversations about a
sexual relationship between Monitor and
stuff okay so we don't release any type
of information related to sexual
assaults that's that's just state law
I can't comment on that go ahead is
really a victim then in all of this or
did he cause did he and his mother work
together I mean he wasn't missing now
the investigation is still going on
according and uh I'm not going to say
that he's a victim or not I'm thinking
you know and and saying we're going to
treat this just as we do with any uh
potential victim our victim and we're
going to give respect um to everybody
that's that's involved we're going to
conduct our investigation and uh we kind
of right at the beginning of it uh this
investigation is going to go on after
this press conference attacks
if if charges are are are you know
appropriate they'll see but let us
conduct the investigation and what's
next Courtney just as any other
investigation we're going to follow our
evidence we're going to do more
interviews I'm going to follow the
evidence and I think that's important go
ahead
we're not going to say that right right
now in any way we're going to conduct
invest investigation it's really too
early to determine that um they're going
to be some uh more parts to the
investigations and and and you know some
of that may come into play but right now
so just because
yeah
that would have been kidnapping right or
holding somebody against their will we
don't have any information to to say
there was any kind of kidnapping or
anything like that right now okay have
any search warrants of being insert
I'll take you soon no search for
watching no at the time he was reported
missing eight years ago
being missing is not a crime so the the
detectives had no lawful means or
probable cause to issue a search warrant
for the residents which was searched
several times we're going to work our
way down and we'll get back to you
go ahead yes
there is no uh the permanent timeline as
you can imagine there's a cost to it and
and there there's some complications and
give you one just just quick thing of
the challenge 200 of our vehicles are
modeled 200 to 2014
um are older that's a challenge I'm not
you know when we're up against a
financial budget like we are
um you know you got to pick and choose
and you got to prioritize some some
things so but as quickly as funding
comes in we're going to work to get in
all of our Patrol vehicles and those
vehicles that come into contact
um with the public with dash cams but I
want people to realize one thing a
hundred percent of our officers that's
out there on the streets have body worn
cameras on 100 percent and um we know
for a fact that if you would choose dash
cams I'd love to have out both systems
okay 100 but once you get out that car
where most things happen in an
interaction hand in hand I want that
body worn camera but as we get funding
in and as I said uh the mayor
um is stepping up and like he always
does but he can only do so much this
funding issue didn't start and I'm gonna
say this I stay away from politics okay
but the citizens in Houston at some
point in time we're going to have to
really face how we're going to fund
properly fund Public Safety uh and
public servants okay because you need
better fire trucks you need better
equipment we can't keep kicking that can
down the street we're gonna have to talk
about things of of a revenue cap but
we'll leave it to the politicians next
question go ahead
in between yesterday and the day that he
was discovered was anything searched was
was anybody questioned did anybody go by
the house
Rudy and his mother were
interviewed yesterday
um
as far as anyone going to the house
it's it's still active investigation who
can't release details pretending to that
also quick clarity
yes sir that's correct
25 now yeah go ahead Mario I'll get you
all up go ahead
that was in March 7th of 2015. so there
was a missing person's report that was
filed
correct and so this is what I'm asking
about this thing
could the mother be detained
for filing a missing person's report
and never once informing HPD that he
came home
yes she could be reported or detained
that offense is a Class C misdemeanor
which is similar to a Tropic citation
Rudy farius was found on Thursday your
investigator spoke to him nearly a week
later do you think it was a mistake not
to speak to him sooner you said yourself
the D.A has not accepted charges that's
a week where evidence could be destroyed
what's your response to that
so it's it's
procedure
for the investigation to go through a
channel and when it reaches us we review
it there was no
urgency
to investigate a recovered or found
person and I say that because Patrol
officers made contact with him they
ensured that he was safe they contacted
hfd to make sure that he didn't need
medical treatment and he was cleared on
scene by hfd
they refused he refused transportation
in the hospital his mother took him to
the hospital later on that what the
lieutenant said I think is important huh
you can't force a potential victim of a
missing person okay with nothing else to
come in and give a statement so we it
takes time to try to work with people to
get that statement and chief I know you
believe in transparency and I just for
the public we're going to put this on
the news and it's going to cause more
questions because yesterday we hear from
the activists who makes these shocking
allegations and as a reporter who was
there I did see him myself go in and out
of the room so it was clear that he had
some sort of communication transparency
doesn't come in in front and maintaining
Integrity of the investigation and
that's that's where my transparency
stops but and I'm gonna it's the last
question I'm asked about the activists
or anybody else else
um you know we're going to follow our
investigation and we treat it the same
uh everybody has a role in society and
we respect everybody including all
activists but the Integrity of the
investigation is number one and we're
going to maintain that and going inside
that room to about jeopardize the
investigation by allowing him I don't
think so but
at this moment and his mom
yes sweetie really is safe
he is with his mother by choice
yeah he's a 25 year old man right hey
we're going to get a few more Mario
right here and then we're gonna work our
way down probably four more we're gonna
wrap
I said potential victim and I want to be
respectful on that yep
17. years old
there's been cases in the past where
people have been brainwashed where
people have been told you cannot and
they're being held against their will
for everyone that's going to be watching
this worldwide because this is a
worldwide story
how do you not separate him until you
guys are able to get everything together
considering that he disappeared as a
child Mario you've been in a business
for a long time and I'm gonna let I'm
gonna let you answer that okay we've
explained uh everything
um some of the challenges and whatnot
here's a fact he's a grown man
20 listen to what I'm saying if you want
me to want me to ask you no no he was an
adult 17. hold up okay
um not confrontational you know I
respect whatever everybody does okay but
but
17 years old that's an adult in the
state of Texas okay a lot of things that
we shared up here so uh we're gonna work
our way through it uh it takes a little
while
there's a lot of development still even
last night okay we we know that
everything's coming up we're going to
investigate it the Integrity is going to
stay in place we're going to treat him
the same as any other person that comes
through that we're conducting
investigation on I'm done with that part
go ahead Courtney
okay anybody
what can you tell us about why Rudy and
his mother then allegedly lied for eight
years
and said he was missing one he clearly
wasn't I can answer that though I mean
to protect we can't predict motivation
or whatnot we could just try to yeah
right yeah
but you know during the interview and
the particulars of it it's active
investigation and we respect that but
okay yeah
next question yep
we wasn't we wasn't just um doing eight
years total investigation okay so it
went dormant for a little bit but the
case was still open okay and and it's
and I want to say this until we find
people until we clear it that that's
when it should be clear but uh if your
question is
they were we expended some resources
absolutely
yes
age
no you just you're prioritizing okay um
it's it's uh we're in a a budget um that
there are challenges okay and what I've
presented and I will side note this okay
because it takes a little while to
explain it
um when you have challenges and people
look at a a one billion dollar budget
okay and everybody just oh my God HPD
has a lot of money
91 92 percent of that goes to salary and
benefits so it's not a whole lot of
money uh we have to pay our people and
we have to be uh uh competitive uh the
mayor just gave 7.2 million so we can
get more Cadets in so there there are a
lot of challenges and what I'm saying is
this didn't happen just in the marriage
uh uh um Administration for years you
need so much amount 14 million I always
talk about that
um to to properly replace vehicles in
our in our in our Fleet but some years
when things are just you got a lot of
stuff going on okay uh when you don't
get that it kicks it back and it makes
it worse we have an Asian Fleet fifty
percent fifty percent of our vehicles
are a little bit more are Beyond
the the replacement life and that's
Patrol Vehicles a hundred thousand miles
five years unmarked Vehicles 120 000
miles seven years okay so we have a very
agent Fleet and a lot of other problems
so we are prioritizing we're going to
get there where we need to but outside
State go ahead yes
no
no we're not going to say anything let
me get you and then I'm gonna get you
you're gonna be the last one go ahead
you guys want to talk about that call
for service we we can it's a call for
service uh there was a burglary report
last night at the house uh Patrol
responded and uh we were alerted because
it was a house of of note and we were
it's now it's it's been part of the
investigation and that is also now part
of our investigation what happened last
night you said in the beginning of this
press conference that Rudy has made
contact with Patrol units at some point
can you explain what that was and does
he face any charges for saying that he
had false names
so it is a criminal offense to to give
false names when you're uh
detained under arrest or you're making a
Valley's report there was an instance
where he did that him and his mother at
this time though the district attorney
has declined to accept charges on that
until our entire investigation so you
tried to charge him as well
it was the facts were presented in the
district attorney Mario we're going to
end it okay can you say what that
contact was quickly though with him you
said Patrol units was it like he was
stopped in his car can you just tell us
did HPD ever go
and with his mother and were any
fictitious names given
hfd I'm sorry excuse me investigators
did go out to the home multiple times
they talked to various family members
relatives friends neighbors and yes they
were given the fictitious name
so was there contact made with Rudy at
his home let me uh let me let me uh
close with this one thing okay let me
close with this Mario
um look we've been open as we can it's
not our first investigation and
everybody here understands what I'm
saying about the Integrity investigation
this is where we're going to end we
wanted to get up before
um a lot because this has come as not
only a local but a national in some
cases International okay because
everything is going on but it ends today
not all investigation uh but as we get
more information and when it's
appropriate
will send out information okay so I want
to thank everybody I want to thank you
for your patience um and and thank y'all
for what you do every day
that's it all right thank y'all
Jimenez
uh
s-t-e-p-h-e-n-j-i-m-e-n-e-z sergeant
detective Brian fort b-r-i-a-n-f-o-r-t
detective Elena claiburn e-l-e-n-a
Claiborne c-l-a-b-u-r-n
Lieutenant Christopher Zamora
c-h-r-i-s-t-o-p-h-e-r Zamora z-a-m-o-r-a
yes sir thank you
thank you